UP MEASURES TO STOP ANY ATTEMPT
TO PACK THE COURTS.
>> Bret: MASSACHUSETTS
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS
TO GET RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
SHE MADE THAT COMMENT DURING A
TOWN HALL MEETING IN
MISSISSIPPI.
>> MY VIEW IS THAT EVERY VOTE
MATTERS.
THE WAY WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IS THAT WE CAN HAVE NATIONAL
VOTING AND THAT MEANS GET RID OF
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> Bret: SUPPORTERS OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE USED SOME OF
THAT SAME ARGUMENT SAYING IT
KEEPS CANDIDATES FROM FOCUSING
SOLELY ON MAJOR POPULATION
CENTERS WHERE LARGE CLUSTERS OF
VOTERS LIVE LIKE NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA.
SPEAKING OF BIG CHANGES,
DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO COMING AROUND
TO THE IDEA OF LOWERING THE
VOTING AGE TO 16.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL TELLS US WHY.
>> THERE'S A PUSH ON THE LEFT TO
ALLOW YOUNGER KIDS TO VOTE IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS,
HOUSE DEMOCRATS TRY TO SHIFT THE
VOTING AGE FROM 18-16.
THEIR ARGUMENT IS YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE MOBILIZING AND PUSHING OLDER
AMERICANS TO ACTION ON ISSUES
RANGING FROM GUN VIOLENCE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THEY ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
LEGISLATIVE AND SOCIAL MOVEMENTS
AND NEVER EARNED INCLUSION IN
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> 179 VOTES BUT A MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS FAVORED IT.
>> THE AMENDMENT IS NOT ADOPTED.
>> SO DOES A HOUSE SPEAKER WHO
HAS ALWAYS FAVORED LOWERING THE
VOTING AGE.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO CAPTURE
KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN THEY
ARE LEARNING ABOUT GOVERNMENT TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE.
>> SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL FIRED BACK THERE IS
NO NEED TO DRIVE TURNOUT.
>> WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
WE HAD THE BIGGEST ELECTION
TURNOUT SINCE 1966 LAST YEAR.
IF THE IDEA HERE IS TO MAKE IT
MORE LIKELY WE HAVE A HIGHER
TURNOUT, IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> OTHER REPUBLICANS ARE
COUNTERING DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE CONVINCED
IT WOULD BENEFIT THEM.
>> THEY THINK MORE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO VOTE
DEMOCRAT, THEY THINK IT WILL
HELP THEM, JUST LIKE THEY THINK
ALLOWING NONCITIZENS WILL HELP
THEM, IT'S ALL DESIGNED TO HELP
DEMOCRATS AND HELP THEM ON
ELECTION DAY.
>> A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
FORMER DNC CHAIR AND SAYS IT
DOES NOT HURT TO TRY.
>> 16-YEAR-OLDS, 17-YEAR-OLDS
ARE READY, THEY ARE ENGAGED AND
WANT TO GET INVOLVED.
IF THEY WANT TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
>> THE VOTING AGE WAS LOWERED TO
18 BUT IT TOOK A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT AND PART OF THE PITCH
WAS IF YOU ARE OLD ENOUGH TO